happy friday how is everyone
[Music]
cool cool i am excited we're
we're doing more we're gonna we're gonna
keep talking about xrd today
we're gonna pick up where we left off so
i filled in some numbers
and then we're going to fill out this
chart and really get to a deep
understanding
of xrd i'll also talk about mosley's law
and and a little bit about another type
of xrd that
that is done now
where were we oh okay we were here
so on wednesday uh and i wanna
before we fill this chart out i want to
go back and make sure
we kind of get this right we talked
about the bragg condition
and we talked about um how
you know the the unique thing about
about
x-rays is that their wavelengths are
right
in that in that you know in that sort of
precious distance regime of the spacing
of atoms in a crystal
and so if i if i shine them on the
crystal
then they can diffract and they can have
constructive and
destructive interference but only
if they sort of line up right and that's
what the brag diffraction tells us
it tells us the condition the brag
condition
for when they line up and in particular
this is a a pretty nice
uh image okay so you can see here's
one ray coming in one x-ray coming in
and it's a wave
it's a wave so it's going to be a wave
that goes like that and it bounces off
this surface now a second one
doesn't bounce off that top surface it
bounces off of the one
beneath it okay and they're separated by
a distance d
so this could be any set of planes right
so if you take this
so here are my planes now so so these
black atoms are are one
plane right but these yellow ones are
another one
that's another plane that you could see
remember one of the assumptions of the
bragg condition
is that these planes are like mirrors so
we lose a sense of where the atoms are
exactly and we just
write a mirror there we say it's
reflecting off the mirror so where's the
next one right
you can take the orange ones that's
another plane the red ones and so forth
right so that's what you're you're now
you're you have a wave on top
okay you've got a wave on top and you've
got a wave coming down and bouncing off
the one beneath it and
for those to constructively interfere
so that you pick up a signal in the
detector right
there's only one way for that to happen
and that's if this distance
plus that distance is equal to a
multiple of the wavelength
right and that is the bright condition
you can see why
it comes off why doesn't it you know it
has to come all the way down to here
which makes that theta equal to that
theta you see that because
they've gone up to this point up to that
line they've gone the same distance so
they're waving together
right and it's that point where now this
is the extra
that the one that bounces off of this
plane that's the extra distance
it goes that's the bragg condition okay
that's the practitioner remember in this
class okay so it could be any
uh multiple but but here we're just
gonna assume n equals one because it's
in
the easiest case okay good that's the
brag condition
now um then we did something beyond just
just that because that tells us
you know what the wavelength has to be
to get a spot to get
something the detector can see because
it constructively
interferes everything else is
destructive no signal
right but we did one more thing right we
also said that d for some
set of planes remember this hkl is just
telling me which one of these i'm
talking about
that's what hkl is i'm saying we're
going to pick one of these planes
and the distance between them is d h k l
okay good
and and what we know from before from
our miller
times we know that that is equal to the
square root
of a squared plus k squared plus l
squared for the cubic lattices we're
talking about
right so you see it's kind of brag plus
miller
brag plus distance
miller right miller cubic
that's what we're really combining here
the distance given by this formula when
we talk about miller planes
that combined gave us
this lambda over 2
a squared equals
sine squared theta h k l
over h squared plus k squared
plus l square and all i've done is you
know substitute and square
okay and we did one more thing on
wednesday
and we talked about constants and we
said well if something's equal to a
constant
then it's a constant right that's some
good math
that's some good math and so we said
well that's the whole beauty of these
characteristic x-rays
because if you take like a k-alpha line
from copper it's always 1.4 1.54 sorry
angstroms
it's always lambda equals 1.54
that's what's so nice about it doesn't
depend on anything else just the the
metal you put in there is the target
it's called a target because you're
you're targeting it with electrons so
the copper target k
alpha lambda constant lattice constant
that's built into the name constant
constant equals the angle
and the plane it's reflecting off of and
so our
our job then in crystallography and
doing x-ray diffraction
our job is to figure out how to keep
this thing a constant
the same constant all right that's what
constant means
okay that's our job and that's that's
where we left off and we say okay well
let's take this to the next level
let's do an actual experiment now how do
you do experiments well
you have equipment and this is what a
really cool xrd machine looks like
this is what happens when you don't have
any money and
so this is what's in my lab but you see
it's true you can come see it but you
see the the point is
they do the same thing we don't need
fancy equipment at mit
no we can it's the ideas that matter
that you're putting into this thing
but that's kind of cool still i like the
way that looks
same thing right source sample
detector that's hard to see but source
sample detector from the 60s
ish okay
all right but so now it's easier of
course you can understand i mean some of
these things
have different ways of doing but you can
understand like changing the angle is
going to be easier to move that sample
right
and then maybe the detector moves but
you might keep the the source
x-rays fixed and what happens well you
do this and you generate a spectrum
right so
so you're changing the angle you're
keeping this
fixed and you're saying what do i got
okay well here in this case i'm telling
you what i got i got aluminum
i put aluminum in there and i shot
x-rays
and i have to you cannot if anybody
gives you an xrd pattern they got to
tell you
what kind of uh x-rays they use right
that's really important or at some point
you got to know this this is pretty
important
the lambda is from a copper target and
the k alpha lines is 1.54 angstroms
and this is the spectrum and i'm being
asked to get the crystal structure
of aluminum and the lattice constant and
i can get that because look
i can simply read off peaks and those
are the peaks and i've kind of
highlighted them there
two theta right two theta remember we
for more for historical reasons you you
take two theta measurements
even though in the bragg condition it's
just theta okay we can divide
by two right and so here are those first
four peaks
now i've just listened to them here peak
one two three four here
one sine squared of you know half of
that goes in tight
okay there it is and then we have our
recipe and i gave you this recipe as a
way
to keep this constant right
it's an easier way to do it if you if
you scale
and clear fractions it's just easier
right so that's why i've given you that
recipe
so let's do that so first would
normalize what does that mean well you
have the smallest value of sine squared
theta i'm just going to divide
everything
by that okay so that's where we left off
1
because that's what i'm normalizing by
and then this one would be
1.33 and this one would be
2.67 and this one would be
3.67 and so that's good but i don't want
fractions
it's going to be easier for me to think
about this as integers
and so we clear fractions what does
clear fractions mean
that clear the fractions get rid of them
make it integers how do you do that
find what you multiply this by so that
they're all integers
okay i got an idea how about three
times three in this case times three
equals three okay good and in this case
well i don't need to i don't mean okay
anyway times three
equals four times three
don't multiply by a different number
right
i'm clearing the fractions for the whole
table i'm multiplying by the same number
okay good eight and this is times
three equals 11. so i've got
3 4 8 11 and that's
what i need to work with that's what i
need to work with because now
you see it's now you know and i hope
it's kind of starting to make some sense
if this if i can get this to be
h squared plus k squared plus l squared
well then i've done my job i've kept
this constant
that's the trick right i've done my job
i've just made the math easy
if i can get h squared plus k squared
plus l squared
to equal these things right then i'm
keeping a count so let's see what what
would that be
well here it would be so this has to be
h squared let me just write it here plus
k squared
plus l squared okay
i want those to be an a squared plus k
so if i do that well this
looks a whole lot like one one one that
works
and for four two zero zero
okay and for eight two two zero
and finally for eleven three one
one oh
it's a beautiful thing i've gone from
angles
to planes these are planes
h k and l mean one of these
they it means one of those that's what
it means a set
of those right and i have found now
which ones literally which ones give me
each peak this peak is the 1 1 1 plane
it's x-rays bouncing off of that
reflecting off of that and the one below
it and the one below it
and seeing where it gives you
constructive interference
and gives you the back condition and
therefore a peak
okay all right now hold on
hold on now okay have we determined
have we determined the crystal structure
have we determined the crystal structure
can anybody who
how do we get the crystal structure from
this from these peaks
how do we get well let's see okay um
it could it let's see could it be um
could it be bcc
what else did we learn on wednesday
right
what else did we learn on wednesday we
learned about selection rules
you got to remember the selection rules
those factor
in so let's write those down here let's
remind ourselves of
okay that's important right
now i mentioned how this came about
i don't need you to uh
know how to derive the selection rules
but i did talk about why they come about
right because you could for some of
these cuts
you could have a plane in between
that destroys the signal okay depending
on
which which crystal structure it is and
which plane you're talking about
and when it comes down to it for simple
cubic
it's anything goes anything
oh polonium and for bcc
it's adds
to an even number and for fcc
no mixing
no mixing of odd and even
those are the selection rules you don't
need to know how to derive them but i do
want you to know what they are
those are the so now we can see well
okay hold on if this were a bcc
crystal and they had to add to even one
plus one
plus one is three bam
it's not bcc right yeah okay
good but but but now hang on if it's no
mixing on even
did i handle that one okay yeah
odd even even odd
this looks like an fcc crystal than me
all right
this looks like an fcc crystal and i can
go even further i can calculate the
lattice constant
i can calculate the lattice constant
because it's right here
it's right here right
so that's the lattice constant that's a
number that's a constant
lambda so i could take any one of those
planes
any one of those any one of these four
peaks
and i and if i if i did this right
if i did this right they better give me
the same lattice constant
and that's actually the last step in the
recipe did i put the right yes
all right this is the recipe i gave you
on on wednesday to for you all to become
crystallographers x-ray de fractioners
that's okay we'll make it work you're
x-ray diffractioners
and and the thing is you got to remember
how powerful this is
how powerful this is because you we've
learned about perfect crystals and now
we've just gotten the single most
one the single most important way to
figure out which one we have
we shine x-rays on it and we look for
diffraction peaks that's it this is a
very powerful tool
and it is used all over the place in
in materials chemistry physics you name
the field
x-ray diffraction is a starting point
for characterizing
the crystal and so the last sanity check
that you want to do here
because it'll help you make sure you did
these points correctly
is compute these values
because you know this this is it right
sine
squared over a squared plus k squared
plus l squared
better be a constant
if it's not then you've done something
wrong in this analysis
right you can just calculate the lattice
constant for each peak
and they also better agree and so i
won't do that but it turns out we did it
right
for each one of these that is indeed a
constant we have
achieved our goal
with great power comes great
responsibility
how you use xrd how you use xrd
well let's see let's use it to figure
out what phase of material we have
but this is why does this matter right
well i have why this matters
but but there's multiple reasons for why
this matters
the as as i think we've talked about you
know the properties of a material depend
on the chemistry and the material but
they also depend on the structure of the
material
and we're making solids so those
structures are crystals
until next week when we destroy the
crystals by putting defects in them
but for now they're these perfect
crystals and they have this kind of
repeating pattern
don't worry about hcp bcc ah
we're comfortable fcc comfortable bcc
now
this is called a phase diagram
this is called a phase diagram phase
diagrams will be on the quiz next week
i'm kidding they're not going to be on
the quiz because this isn't a class
about phase diagrams
but but i want you to know i want you to
know
what a phase diagram is it is a map
of materials it is a very important it
is like a
treasure map literally because you find
i need
iron to have a different property oh if
i go to this pressure and that
temperature
aha it can have a different property why
because it has a different crystal
structure so the crystal structure of
something
in this case it's iron depends on the
pressure and temperature
and and the properties depend on the
crystal structure
so we've got a way now to change
materials
same element i'm just changing its
structure
i love this one this is water now dude
you know don't worry about how complex
this is
actually the whole point is it's complex
this is the phase diagram of water now
this doesn't even have them all there
are 17 current phases
of ice 17 different
crystalline structures of ice that is
incredible
right now you you can actually imagine
why
from your knowledge in this class
already those are hydrogen bonds
they're kind of strong but they're not
too strong there's a lot of ways that
those
water molecules could form a solid and
they do
17 to date and counting but see
and this tells you which one you have
now earth's operating conditions are
right around here
and that's a really good thing because
there's a liquid phase and there's ice
one
is here i h is ice one and it's a really
good thing because of the fish
because if you if it weren't ice one
then
when it freezes it wouldn't have you
know a different density and the ice
wouldn't float to the top and the fish
could still live
which they do in the winter because you
don't freeze from the bottom you freeze
from the top
that's because it's ice one and not ice
eight
it would be terrible right but yet we
know about these and how do we know
we know because of crystallography we
know because of
xrd we can figure out
yeah if you're out and maybe this is
it's a friday night so maybe this is a
good idea it's a good time to mention it
you might get ice in your water out at a
restaurant
how do you know which kind of ice it is
talk about xrd as the only real way to
figure out which one of these
you really have okay so for example if i
were
to uh think of other types of problems
you might get well here's a good one
okay here's a good one so um
so this is a an x-ray diffraction
spectrum and i give it to you and i
don't even tell you what it is
why is it here's a pattern that i put
something in there
and i measure these peaks and i tell you
the source it's the k
alpha line of copper so that's the
wavelength of the source
first thing is what what lattice
what symmetry does this
does this correspond to is this is it
simple cubic
body centered cubic or face centered
cubic can we get that
we can get that because of the exact
same
thing that we just talked about right
there this this cannot be if it were
simple cubic you'd see the peaks
but no whether some peaks are forbidden
so they don't show up
right and you only get peaks that look
like an fcc
according to our selection rules no
mixing odd even
that works so this is an fcc crystal so
i've already learned that
and then i say well what's the okay use
the 1 1 1 peak
to calculate the lattice constant okay
oh we can do that right so if i
if i were to uh the one one one peak is
even labeled there it's 38 degrees
ah 38 degrees
and so so 2 theta is 38 degrees
so that means that theta okay i can do
this one
is 19 degrees okay
now oh from brag lambda equals
2 d sine theta but look
label label the plane
this corresponds to a plane so some
distance between some planes corresponds
to some
angle that gave me constructive
interference for those planes let's pass
this around so you guys can
look at these planes they're beautiful
things
now that means that if i
if i look at the first peak i know what
late well i i've labeled them here
in the last one i didn't and you want to
find those here i'm giving you
the planes so if i do that then
d one one one equals
lambda over 2 sine
theta 1 1 1 which equals 2.37 angstroms
okay have i answered the question i
haven't answered the question yet
because you see the the question says
what's the lattice constant
well but but i'm very close the lattice
constant
the lattice constant is related because
of miller
the miller plane's equation for lattice
lattice constant
distance between any planes oh this is
all just coming together and so d
one one one is equal to
a over root three
and so a equals four point one angstroms
oh you could go even further yeah you
could figure out now that you know it's
fcc
it's a single atom basis fcc crystal you
could actually figure out the atomic
radius
i got a and i know the closed pack
direction
right i could actually figure out the
atomic radius and i could go into my
periodic table
and figure out what i have just from the
the atomic radii
listed in the periodic table and the
crystal structures
fcc atomic radius
which one is it it's gold it's gold
so this is the kind of thing that you
guys now have
the power to do you have the power to do
this you can go back and forth
between you know based on your knowledge
of crystals and now your knowledge of
x-rays and how x-rays interact with
crystals
you can do this um now uh oh
that went too far now okay so now i'm
gonna get to the
the why this matters um right so
so there's two different uh sources two
different targets remember we
call them sources or targets and
and notice okay copper has
they both have this continuous radiation
and and i will talk about that the bring
stroll them we'll end
with a discussion a little bit on what
you can do with that
um but for now let's keep focused on on
these lines
these discrete characteristic lines so
there's the k alpha for molybdenum
there's the k alpha for copper
okay now mosley
henry mosley
was a brilliant scientist and he was
working with rutherford and others
um and and he was really interested
in looking at the trends
and so so he took all of these elements
so from calcium
all the way to zinc 20 to 30
and he said i want to look at the k
alpha lines
of all of these i want to look at the k
alpha lines of all of these
and what he found was
extraordinary he did more he did more 38
in total but i'm just gonna show you his
data for these
okay and what he did was was absolutely
profound
um because what he noticed there are the
lines these are actually his
measurements okay
these are his k alpha lines
and what he noticed in going from
calcium down
to oh brass okay we'll talk about that
in a minute
it's supposed to be zinc isn't it why is
it z well why is it not zinc let's think
about that later
but for now he noticed that this has
a square root relationship to the energy
so
so mosley came up with in night he was
working on this in 1912
okay you gotta remember
1913 right 1912 is when
rutherford did the gold foil experiments
it had been 44 years since mendeleev
put his periodic table to to paper right
and published that so for 44 years
we had a periodic table but but to see
the thing is there was a
huge problem with the periodic table
because
i mean mendeleev
had this sort of brilliant realization
that the periodicity
periodicity
was related to both the atomic mass and
remember we talked about this
and the properties the chemical
properties
that chemical properties
that allowed him to create an ordering
of the elements
and ordering of the elements that is
still the ordering essentially that we
have today
that but the problem is why did they
have that ordering
i didn't really tell you why sometimes
he was like well the properties win
yeah okay maybe the mass well no no
properties win properties need to be
aligned in this column
so i'm going to move those over like
that's what he did
but he didn't know why except that it
made sense to him
mosley's experiments told us they gave
us the why
oh it was so important um and and
mosley's law
mosley's law
was essentially him thinking about the
bohr model
for these x-rays for these
characteristic x-rays so he said
that um h nu so that's the frequency
for some k alpha line okay is
equal to 13.6 e v oh that looks familiar
times z minus one squared
and then he did the difference in
energies just like we've done now a
number of times in this class
that's what he did and this is
three-fourths
why this well let's talk about that in a
second so 13.6
ev times
three fourths times
z minus one squared
two things about this right one is why
is it
three why is it one over one squared
minus one over two squared well that's
because
they knew or at least they they were
pretty confident that you had this
this positive charge in the middle here
that's the
the protons and the nucleus and then you
have these electrons right so you had
like the two
the 1s electrons and then you had
another shell out here
okay and and so they knew okay 2s
maybe that's combined with 2p so it goes
on
so so what happens in the x-ray
experiment
well what happens is you shoot an
electron in rent can just
crank the voltage up so high that an
electron could come and knock that out
right and so this one that's that's the
that's what did it and so now one of
these
can cascade down there and give off
a k alpha photon
right this is this is nothing new we've
talked about this
but you see it here in the equation you
see it in two ways
first we're going from two to one
one squared minus one half squared
three-fourths
right but second and this was
critical the z minus one
the z minus one told us that
this the all these positive charges in
here
all these positive charges are screened
perfectly by one electron
this one that was left and it works
he assumed perfect screen so there's one
see there's one so what do all these see
they see z minus one they see z minus
one
if z is related to the atomic number
now here's where this was so powerful
because
when you put you can't read this don't
worry about that i just want to show you
that
it is a perfectly straight line when you
plot
the k alpha transitions these are
different elements
right these are his different elements
and if you plot the square root
of the frequency if you plot the square
root of the frequency versus element it
is a perfect line
that holds and and so what mosley wrote
in the paper is we have here a proof
in 1913 that there is in the atom a
fundamental quantity a fundamental
quantity
which increases by regular steps as one
passes from one element to the next
this quantity can only be only b the
charge on the central positive nucleus
of the existence of which we already
have definite proof now we know about
that
we know right from the experiments that
rutherford did
that that nucleus had the positive
charge but they didn't know
that it was connected to the position in
the periodic table
in fact years later um
people talking about those experiments
at this time and said people didn't even
take rutherford's experiments
as seriously until mosley's work came
along
44 years had come since
mendeleev but mosley gave it the
foundation that it needed
periodicity is because
of atomic number periodicity
is atomic number that was not known
that z gives you the periodicity right
and that gives you
also the number of protons
this was a time when they didn't know
what was going on why did the mass
change so much the neutron wasn't
discovered until 1932
20 years later but this gave the
grounding that was needed
to the chemistry of the periodic table
it's a very important discovery
very very important discovery so that's
my why this matters and it's it's um
it's a real it's it's really tragic
because um he died
tragically in world war one at age 27
and many the nobel prize was not given
in 1916 for either physics or chemistry
he died in 1915
and most people at the time believed
that he would have won it at age 28.
um that's how important that discovery
was
okay let's go back to brass i gotta go
to brass what's going on here
what is going on with brass right
any ideas
why didn't he just put zinc there
dude it looks so good until brass
what is going on well here
i'll give you a hint okay the melting
temperature
let's see brass okay zinc
melts around
420c
brass which equals
zinc and copper
melts at around 900 c
or or more greater than 900 c
that's a hint because if we go back to
the video let's go back
oh the sound is on those are the
electrons
small portion of the top let me let me
set that up the electrons are
because i'm doing in the middle the
electrons are coming off of cathode
because rankin has cranked the voltage
way up and pumped all the air out so
those electrons are coming off with
thousands and thousands of kev okay
they're coming out and that's what's on
the right here
there there is shaped to focus the
electrons onto a small portion of the
target
which increases the intensity of the
x-rays produced
the target is typically a piece of
tungsten or molybdenum
which may be embedded in a stationary
water or oil-cooled rod
or on a rotating disc the high speed
electrons
collide with the target and rapidly lose
energy
there are two x-ray producing
interactions between the incident
electrons and the atom
oh look at the power you can feel
the power coming into that tiny little
piece of metal
right you know and now some of the some
of the time you get the
the transition that we talked about you
knock an electron out
and you emit a photon a k alpha photon
or maybe an l
beta photon right uh and sometimes you
slow the electron down so you get the
bremsstrahlen
yeah but but but there's so much energy
being pumped into this material
and a lot of times those electrons just
collide and heat up the metal
that metal is getting extremely hot
and in these experiments either you
cooled it
or you might rotate it quickly right so
that it gets to cool down it gets a
little break
right or you do both or you just throw
up your hands and you say you know what
i'm just gonna go for an alloy
that's got some zinc in it but won't
melt every time
yeah it was a good idea so you put brass
in okay you're gonna get the copper
lines but you'll get the zinc lines
you'll get the zinc lines right now that
and then that that was why he used brass
and that's why you can see you get extra
lines in the case of brass
all right okay
good all right now i'm
very excited about mosley he you know
it allowed us to actually understand
this not just because
look at this mendeleev was like you know
what
cobalt and nickel can't be swapped hey
all you people who just think about mass
you're not going to put them in the
order you think i'm changing that
right i'm changing it because properties
matter
mosley said no you're changing it
because
it's the right order because of the blue
numbers
you're changing it because there is an
actual count here that matters
and that is why your periodic table is
what it is
absolutely critical it put the
lanthanides in the right place
it allowed the prediction of elements
you know
like hafnium and a number of others uh
that hadn't been discovered yet
um and it set it all on this much more
solid uh
grounding so that is the contribution of
moses
i i can't help it i gotta i'm very
excited so
i brought t-shirts i knew i was talking
about mosley
now i'm going okay
all right there and in the middle
and over there and over there
and over there oh that
that's a bad arm
[Applause]
and up there and uh hold on hold on now
okay there there and this is all for
mosley
this is all for mosley
[Applause]
all right now
okay
now uh a part
apart from me um showing off i don't
have much of an arm
one thing i'd like to say is if you did
already get a t-shirt please just hand
it off to a friend or somebody you know
let's let's share sherry is
always caring now um there's another
type of x-ray
i want to talk about and um
see actually this is much less used
today
i i hope you've gotten a sense of how
powerful these characteristic x-rays are
you know exactly what the wavelength is
um but in the very earliest xrd
experiments it was the bremsstrahlung
radiation that was used and that was by
von lawy so i want to just tell you
about that
and and so here's an example of an mo
target now let's remind ourselves
what we're looking at these are
x-rays these are x-ray intensities
versus wavelength
and and this corresponds to 5 10 15 20
that corresponds
to the kilo electrons that's the
thousands of electron volts
of the incoming electron that electron
that came in here
and knocked this out from the cathode
right
okay now that electron if it comes in
and we talked about this already
but let me remind you if it comes in at
a kind of low energy well you're still
going to get
this continuous spectrum this continuous
spectrum
oh why does it look like that beyond the
scope of what we need to know but
but in case you're wondering it has to
do with very complicated effects
that happen when things when x-rays come
off and then are reabsorbed
right by the same material you can
imagine that that could lead to all
sorts of interesting
cascades of absorption and emission
that's what leads to the shape but we
don't need to know
those details what we need to know is
that as you increase the power of those
incident electrons
you're going to get more and more
intensity of x-rays and this goes down
this wavelength
of the the minimum wavelength or maximum
energy
of the continuous spectrum the maximum
energy goes up
because the maximum energy you can get
in the continuous spectrum is equal to
the incident electron itself so it's set
right remember the duane something limit
dwayne hunt okay we talked about that
already
how to get that value yeah but then you
get to this certain point and look all
of a sudden
the characteristic lines appear right
and those are the k
alpha lines for molybdenum why all of a
sudden well because you got over
the amount of energy needed
to kick out a 1s electron from
molybdenum that's exactly why
before that you had enough energy to
produce x-rays but not enough
to kick out the 1s electron it's kicking
out the 1s electron that gives you
characteristic peaks
okay good this is all reminder stuff but
i want to get back on that page
but see now okay this continuous part is
also used
and it was used like i said by von lauer
and von um was
again a really really smart uh smart
cookie
and he he he used the brag condition
okay to prove that the x-rays and the
space lattice structure of crystals
can be interfered with each other to
make this diffraction
but what he did was was different okay
so the nobel prize was given for this
epoch making discovery
and i'm actually very happy that the
people that worked with him
also shared the nobel prize right
walter and paul what they did was
different though they took this
continuous spectrum
and instead of having so instead of
fixing the angle
and the lambda i'm sorry instead of
varying the angle but having a fixed
lambda
they did the opposite because the cons
the continuous spectrum
has all lambdas right
and so you can imagine how this works
right you can imagine how this works so
in
in the lawyer version of xrd
you shoot uh the x-rays which have all
the wavelengths in them
at a crystal that's fixed i'm not
changing the angle
okay i'm not changing the angle and what
you get
are still diffraction peaks you get
spots
all right so in laway xrd
in lao xrd you have a single crystal
it's got to be the same everywhere in
this case
you have a single crystal theta is fixed
right you don't move it around but
lambda varies
continuously
okay and the pattern
that you get reflects the symmetry
pattern
reflects
the crystal symmetry
how is that possible well you can
actually see this
uh um by thinking about the
do i have another picture i just have
his one you you can see this by thinking
about that that model which is
somewhere out there in the sea
where is the model i don't see it yeah
ah all the way in the back waving around
um
if i if i see if i can draw this let's
see
if i if i shoot i'm not gonna try
if i shoot x-rays that have a fixed
lambda in
but i vary the angle then as we've been
talking about there's gonna be
you know certain angles where you get
constructive interference now if i
if i keep the thing fixed and i shoot
all
lambdas into it well take a look at the
crystal
imagine that i'm holding that structure
right now okay
well i'm going to see this set of planes
here
so so i'm going to see this set of
planes maybe there's a 100 planes i
don't know
all right and i'm going to bounce off of
that and constructively interfere maybe
if i've got the right lambda
but see if i'm looking at the crystal
and it's fixed i'm going to see also
there's another set of planes
like that you see there's another set of
planes like that
and if i'm a different wave like not the
same one but a different one
i might constructively interfere with
those but you can see that the angle
that i make would be different and so
i'll put a spot in a different place
you see so
so i've got all the wavelengths there
and and as they constructively interfere
with different planes
that they see they make different spots
they make different spots and that's
what those are
in those spots it's it's more
complicated to get crystal structure
from those spots it's more complicated
you can get symmetry
fairly easily but you but but getting
the structure itself
is is a little bit more complicated and
can be tricky um
and and and for that and other reasons
most of most work today is done
with characteristic characteristic peaks
xrd
um but but this was this happened before
and so i wanted to show it to you and
this
this resolved actually in in one of
lowe's very famous papers it resolved
the structure of zinc sulfide
it was very important work and those are
the spots there's a look at that pattern
there
see the thing that you could get is the
symmetry oh by the way
by the way we will only test i'm not
going to test you on lowe i'm only
talking about it for five minutes here
right so so in this class i want you to
know about
about you know using characteristic
peaks and all the things we've been
talking about laoway is just
on the side for knowledge we won't test
on this
but i want to end by telling you a story
this this tells you something about
crystal symmetry
what is symmetry well it just means if i
rotate it
is it the same or if i translate it is
it the same give me just
give me just one minute because this is
actually a really interesting story
that's translational symmetry we looked
at this picture
already there's no rotational symmetry
to get back to this picture i'd have to
rotate the whole thing by 360 degrees
but see there are crystals that actually
have
only rotational symmetry and no
translational symmetry
and dan sheckman was the one who
discovered these in the 1980s
nobody believed him his advisor
told him to go back and read the book
and you know who wrote the book
linus pauling linus polling wrote the
book on chemical bonds
literally the book was called the
chemical bond
and linus pauling took the lead he won
two nobel prizes not one he took the
lead in attacking shekman
shekman had discovered quasi crystals
shechman had discovered quasi crystals
but nobody he was fired his papers were
published and for ten
years nobody believed him linus pauling
said famously there are no such things
as quasi crystals
only quasi scientists that's how bad it
was
but shechman had his day he won the
nobel prize
and he had his day and he was proven
right and these quasi crystals are
absolutely fascinating rotational but no
translational symmetry
have a great weekend
you